quelques conseillers du cou à cette
période comme un contact us comme chaque
semaine money devient repérer les
derniers arrivages de cactus en grande
passionnée cette vue en courtoise en
possède une dizaine chez elle il ya
beaucoup de variétés ça permet aussi
d'avoir des plantes toute l'année qu'il
dure qui reste fleuris ou pas fleuri
monique n'est pas la seule à avoir été
piqué par la fièvre du cactus magasins
en vend 500 chaque semaine à partir du
printemps pour un chiffre d'affaires de
2000 euros hebdomadaires
leur best seller les miniatures qui
fonctionne très bien ici c'est le petit
cactus que vous avez là par exemple
tous ces modèles là comme ceci avec des
petites fleurs qui sont très attrayantes
ceci également alors ça s'appelle des
jumeaux calcium
c'est des cactus qui sont qui sont
greffées dans les premiers cactus et la
boule à les greffer dessus des
miniatures qu'on peut également observer
à la borie tome de versailles chèvreloup
à rocquencourt en compagnie de trois
cents autres espèces de cactus mais qui
n'ose rsa en fleurit j'adore ces fleurs
elles sont magnifiques
pour les spécialistes qui travaillent
dans la structure l'engouement autour de
ces plantes commencé il ya six ans ne
risque pas de s'essouffler y correspond
parfaitement aux envies du public
ils ont tellement des formes différentes
des couleurs différentes que il y en a
une palette assez impressionnante
il y en a pour tous les goûts alors je
pense aussi que le cactus a un avantage
c'est que l'entretien est très facile
pas beaucoup d'arrosage
ils tolèrent à peu près tout ils peuvent
partir en vacances tranquilles leurs
plantes elles resteront en bon état et
il n'y a pas de soucis pas une passion
pour le cactus qui s'exporte également
chez les restaurants évinois dans ce
concept store de montfort l'amaury
ouvert il ya seulement quelques mois
la plante est présente dans tous les
recoins sa présence devient même un
argument marketing
je suis pas inspiré mais moi j'aime
j'aime bien ça me fait penser un peu
dans le haut des airs et j'aime beaucoup
le désert je pense que les gens rentrent
aussi pour que ce restaurant se
transforme encore un peu plus en désert
américain les propriétaires vont
recevoir dans les prochains jours une
livraison de plusieurs dizaines de
cactus
le restaurant prévoit également de
préparer des boissons et des planons
piquant à base de cette plante